Ahem! Professor Luxcraft’s Introduction to…Sprytes
for the benefit of tiny humans.
Greetings, humans!
My name is Professor Luxcraft!
Can you see me okay?
Good. Not all humans can see Sprytes you see
but clearly you are one of the special ones.
Now, most humans don’t even know we Sprytes exist,
but the truth of it is Sprytes are everywhere.
We Sprytes are the creators and guardians of everything
you humans would call ‘the natural world.’
The Cloud Sprytes, and Mountain Sprytes, and,
oh, look! There’s one now!
A Forest Spryte!
You see, didn’t I tell you?
But that’s just the beginning.
Sprytes come in many shapes and sizes.
There are Forest Sprytes who make trees,
and Dream Sprytes who make dreams,
and Rabbit Sprytes, and Rain Sprytes,
and Rock Sprytes, and Bird Sprytes,
and Time Sprytes, and Ice Sprytes
and every Spryte has a role to play in creating things
for the human realm.
But, of course, that is only once they’ve discovered
what kind of Spryte they are destined to be.
Young Sprytes must go through intensive training
and learn how to hone their Spryte powers
before they can play their parts.
That’s all I have to tell you for now.
If you want to learn more, you’ll have to come and
visit us in the Everything Factory.
To get there you need to find a portal.
But where would you find one?
[chuckles]
I’ll never tell…
[laughter]